Speaking of psychology is taking a holiday break, so we're rerunning one of our favorite episodes from the past year. Last spring, I talked to University of Florida psychologist Aaron Westgate about the surprisingly fascinating topic of boredom. What is boredom? Is it always bad to be bored? What can we do to infuse even these boring times with meaning? As we look toward a long winter of limited socializing and few distractions, these questions seem as relevant as ever. I hope you enjoy this episode from our archives. Speaking of psychology, we'll be back with new episodes starting in January, at which point we will also be going to a weekly schedule. Thank you for listening. The first confirmed case of COVID-19 in the U.S. was identified in January.
《Speaking of psychology》正在放假，所以我们重播了过去一年中我们最喜欢的节目之一。
By March, most of us had been strongly advised, if not ordered, to keep at least six feet away from other people in public and pretty much to confine ourselves to our homes. As a result, many of us are unable to visit friends or family. We can't go out to a movie, to the gym, or out to dinner. In short, the coronavirus has radically curtailed the way many of us live. So are we bored yet? And if we are bored, is that a problem? Is boredom bad? Welcome to Speaking of Psychology, the flagship podcast of the American Psychological Association that explores the links between psychology and everyday life. I'm Kim Mills. What does psychology tell us about boredom? And why should we care?
到三月份时，我们大多数人都被强烈建议（如果不是被命令的话）在公共场合与他人保持至少六英尺的距离，并且基本上把自己限制在家里。
Is boredom even a legitimate area for psychologists to study? What can we do during these strange times to keep from being bored? Or to use our boredom productively? Our guest today is Dr. Aaron Westgate, an assistant professor of psychology at the University of Florida, where she studies boredom, interest, and why some thoughts are more engaging than others. Much of her research has been on the conditions under which people enjoy or do not enjoy their own thoughts. Welcome to speaking of psychology, Dr. Westgate. Thank you so much for having me. Let me start by throwing you a big softball. So what is boredom and how is it different from other states of mental inactivity? So boredom is actually an emotion. There's often a lot of confusion about this. Like, is boredom actually a feeling I have? Is it an emotion?
心理学家研究无聊感是否真是一个合理的领域？
Is it a state where I'm not feeling anything at all? We actually, there's been a lot of debate in psychology about this. But the growing consensus is that boredom is an emotion like any other. that you experience like anger or sadness and that we define it as those cases where you're not able to engage meaningfully in whatever it is that you're doing, either because you're not able to pay attention or because whatever it is that you're doing just doesn't feel meaningful to you. Well, as I mentioned a moment ago, a lot of us are stuck in our homes with very little to distract us. Are you hearing that boredom is on the rise as a result of the COVID-19 pandemic?
在心理学中，关于这一点其实有很多争论。
There's some interesting research out of Italy, actually, that looked at folks in quarantine right now that suggests that they themselves said that the second biggest sort of downside to being stuck at home was lack of freedom first, obviously. But the second most problematic thing that they were experiencing was boredom, even more than the social isolation and feelings of loneliness. So, I think it really depends a lot. I think certainly there are some people who may be home, homeschooling kids and trying to work from home and who are not bored, that if anything, they may be feeling overwhelmed and anxious. But I think there's an awful lot of us who are at home and suddenly find ourselves without the routines that structured our lives or the tasks that we've
意大利其实有一些有趣的研究，他们调查了目前处于隔离状态的人群，结果表明他们自己认为居家隔离带来的第二大劣势是缺乏自由，排在第一位的显然是自由。
spent most of our days doing and stuck with those long sort of periods of time with nothing to do and limits on what you can do about it, I think a lot of us are feeling a bit bored. What made you want to study boredom? I mean, were you sort of in a state of boredom and it hit you that, wow, this is something I need to think about? You know, it's always, I always get a laugh when I tell people I study boredom. We're like, oh, like, you always grew up wanting to like be a boredom researcher. No, absolutely not.
把大部分时间都花在这些事情上，然后被困在那些漫长、无所事事的时间里，而且对此能做的事情有限，我想我们很多人都感到有点无聊。
I don't think that's anything little kids is spying. Haven't heard that one from a kid yet. No, right. I really want to study boredom one day. I sort of fell into studying boredom because I was doing earlier work on whether people enjoy being alone with their own thoughts. So we all find ourselves stuck at times, such as at the stoplight or just, you know, waiting in line when it would be nice if we could sort of sit back mentally and daydream or just sort of enjoy our own thoughts. And when I started graduate school, I was interested in this question. I started doing research on this question and found that A lot of us really struggle to do this. It's not as easy to simply sit back and intentionally have a pleasant daydream as you might think. And in one study, for instance, we even found that when you ask people to do this on demand in the laboratory, we don't, you know, sit down, try to think for pleasure. But if you want, you can shock yourself with this little electric shock here. About 67% of the men and 25% of the women chose to shock themselves rather than just sit and think.
我不认为这是小孩子们会梦想的事情。
And when we asked them why, they kind of looked at us like, well, done. They were like, well, it was really boring. And I'm like, I know it because that's such not an answer, you know? Yeah. Well, I was bored, so I shocked myself. And I was so intrigued by that question. And I sort of pivoted a little from like, why do people enjoy daydreaming? Why is it so hard to daydream?
为什么人们喜欢白日梦？
To like, what is this strange state that makes people willing to shock themselves? Why are they bored? Can we figure out how to make people not bored? And can we understand what people do when they are bored? So I really had sort of a shift that came out of the research I was doing and what the participants themselves were telling us. And I realized, I like to say, boredom is actually pretty interesting. And that's not something I would have said 10 years ago before I started doing this work.
为什么他们会感到无聊？
So that's an interesting study that you did. And I know that you found differences between men and. women. And I'm also wondering, I mean, you can talk about that in a moment, but did people shock themselves more than once? I mean, was it just out of curiosity or do they just sit there and do it a couple of times because what the heck? You know, it's the darndest thing. They did it multiple times. I know. I know. We were like, the results came in and we were like, well, let's give people the benefit of the doubt. Maybe they, you know, just wanted to see if we, maybe they wanted to call our bluff. Maybe they weren't sure if we were really serious about it or maybe they just wanted
你知道，这真是太奇怪了。
to see what would happen. But the majority of people that shocked themselves shocked themselves more than once. And we had one person who we actually excluded from the data because he shocked himself like over, I forget now, it's over like 75 times. Wow. And it was only a- good time, huh? Or something. It was only a 20-minute period or 15-minute period. So we actually had a research assistant go back and see if our machine was even capable of shocking so many times. Maybe like the machine was broken. So this wonderful undergraduate research assistant for science sat there and shocked herself like a hundred times just to see if the machine would work. Wow. So yeah, we don't think it was something like just calling our bluff or, and the other thing
哇。
is that all these people, we gave them a taste of the shock up front and we had them experience it and rate it. They could tell us whether they enjoyed it or didn't enjoy it. And, you know, everyone basically says they don't enjoy it. And we say, okay, like imagine we give you $5, how much would you pay to not be shocked again?
我们说，好的，比如说我们给你5美元，为了不再被电击，你愿意付多少钱？
And most of these people that went on to shock themselves, said they'd pay on average about $2 to not be shocked. And that's, yeah, I know, I know. It's like we're strangers to ourselves. It's a failure of imagination.
大多数继续电击自己的人说，他们平均愿意支付大约2美元来避免被电击。
I think we don't know how we're going to feel in the future. I think we don't realize how boring something might be and how motivated we can feel. we are bored to do something, even to do anything to stop feeling that way. So that raises a question for me, which is whether there's anything useful about boredom or is it detrimental or is it somehow both? D, all of the above. Bortem is useful when it's working correctly. So I always like to say that boredom is like pain.
所以这给我提出一个问题，即无聊是否有任何用处，还是有害的，或者兼而有之？
No one wants to experience pain. Pain is unpleasant. It hurts. But it's also really, really useful because it tells us that there's something wrong going on in our bodies. And it's a way of alerting us to that problem and motivating us to take steps to stop it, right? And boredom and other negative emotions as well act in the same way. Bortem tells us, hey, look, something is wrong in this case that we either can't pay attention to what we're doing because it's too hard or too easy. But because what we're doing doesn't feel meaningful to us.
没有人想体验疼痛。
But whatever it is, boredom says, stop. This is hurting us mentally. Can you do something about it? And so boredom is really important because it signals instances to us when we're not meaningfully engaged in the world. And it gives us an opportunity to fix it. That said, that's only healthy and adaptive in cases where you can do something about it. If you're trapped, for instance, in a room by psychologists with nothing else to do,
所以无聊感非常重要，因为它向我们发出信号，表明我们没有有意义地参与到世界中。
but shock yourself, there's not really any good solution available to you. So in that case, boredom is an adaptive signal, but it can come a problem when we don't have good options on the table to fix it. If you're stuck in the room and you have nothing figuratively to do to stop feeling bored other than to shock yourself, then people will shock themselves. And that obviously is not good. So I do like the analogy that boredom is like pain. It's healthy and useful and important information, but it can become chronic. And when it becomes chronic, it doesn't serve as that useful signal anymore. And we can vary in the ways we respond to it. We really want to treat the underlying cause of that pain or that boredom. We don't want to just treat the bad
所以，在这种情况下，无聊是一种适应性信号，但当我们手头没有好的选择来解决它时，它就会成为一个问题。
feelings and make them go away without fixing those underlying issues. That sounds almost like boredom can morph into depression. Is that what happens to us? It's not clear. There's a lot of discussion and debate right now on what exactly the relationship is between boredom and depression. Bortem is certainly a feature of depression in many cases. People who are depressed often talk about a lack of motivation, an inability to find anything meaningful. They struggle to pay attention. These are all things we see in boredom and many depressed people report feeling bored a lot. What's not clear is if depression causes boredom or if boredom causes boredom, or if boredom causes depression or what I think maybe most likely is that situations that cause chronic boredom.
目前对于无聊与抑郁之间的确切关系有很多讨论和争论。
So being in situations where you're sort of stuck where you don't have any good options on the table, that's going to make you bored. That's also over time going to make you depressed, independent of whether you're bored or not in the meantime. So I think it's very complicated. And that's one of the, you know, there's a few questions that I think that are really at the forefront of bored of research right now. And I think that's one of them is untangling how boredom and, you know,
所以我认为这非常复杂。
depression and a lot of really maladaptive behaviors associated with both of them, like substance use and alcohol use, how they're all interrelated, and who's causing who? Oh, good questions. So are you using brain scans, fMRIs, things like that, to determine when people say they're bored or can you tell based on what their brains look like, whether they're experiencing something other than boredom? So we usually in studies of boredom and all emotion or they rely pretty face validly on what people tell us. There's been a lot of debate in psychology about how do you best measure something like happiness or you measure best measure something like boredom.
哦，好问题。
And the consensus is largely that the best most reliable way is to simply ask people what they're feeling. Now, people can't tell you why they're feeling that way. If you try, if you ask them, why are you bored? They may have theories for it. They may have causal ideas for it. And they may think that's why they're bored. But we know that people can't actually.
现在，人们无法告诉你他们为什么会有这种感觉。
accurately introspect on those things. They can't actually tell us why they're bored because we don't have access to that information mentally. But they can tell us what they're feeling. There is some work looking at boredom in terms of neuroscience. There's not a lot of it. Most of it's been done by James Denkert and his crew out of Canada. I haven't gone that much that direction, partly because of the work by Kristen Lindquist and Lisa Feldman Barrett and others that suggest that there aren't really good neuro markers of specific emotions in the brain, that when you look at anger and sadness and fear, people's brains all kind of look pretty similar, that you can't really reliably distinguish one emotion from each other. So I think there's lots of important neuroscience
这很有趣。
to be done in boredom, but it's not a direction that I've really pursued. That's interesting. So the neurons just fire no matter what. You're feeling something intense, and that's what they see. We're still working on that question, but we do think that what seems to be happening is that there's an affective response. When we say affect, meaning like emotion, that when people are feeling lots of big emotions, you do see lots of activation in the brain. But it's hard to tell just from looking at the brain, whether that's an anger response or a fear response or what exactly is going on in those cases. Back in the days when I used to be able to go outside and see people, I would notice a lot of folks had their phones in their hands all the time. We're using smartphones, tablets, computers,
我们仍在研究这个问题，但我们确实认为，似乎正在发生的事情是有一种情感反应。
constantly. Is that having an impact on our ability to experience boredom? Are we keeping ourselves away from the normal experience of boredom by substituting these screens? You know, that's a question that I always get. And the quick answer is, we don't know. certainly if you look throughout history like every generation has had its version of a smartphone if you look back far enough you start seeing people complain about newspapers
这会对我们体验无聊的能力产生影响吗？
how people are just you know reading on the subway instead of attention to that you know novels were the big vice back in the day when they first came out like oh people are like ignoring the world for these fake melodramas that aren't even real
小说在当年刚出来时也是一大祸害，比如“哦，人们为了这些甚至都不是真的虚构情节剧而忽视了世界”。
so I you know I really wish I had a time machine as a social psychologist. I, like, you know, people always ask, like, if you had a superpower, what would you do? I would time travel and I would take my questionnaires and my studies and I'd go back in time and see. What we do know is when we look at, this isn't exactly boredom, but we do know that when you look at who is best able to daydream or enjoy their own thoughts, there is a very, very, very, very small but significant correlation between the amount of time. spend on their cell phones and the extent to which they get bored when trying to daydream. That the more time you spend on your phones, you're probably a little bit more likely to be someone that has difficulty enjoying your own thoughts and not getting bored by them.
再次强调，这有因果关系吗？
Again, is that causal? Is it that the cell phone use is causing people to have a hard time finding their own thoughts interesting? Or is it that people that are sort of prone to boredom are more likely to pick up their phone? That's really tricky. There was a study. This isn't bored of exactly, but there was a study recently that paid people to not go on social media for a couple of weeks. And they did find that it increased people's happiness and well-being when you sort of paid them to stay off of these social media sites for a while.
我知道。
I know. Oh, like, I guess I'm doomed to be unhappy. Well, another question that occurs to me is whether there's any kind of a link between, say, overall intelligence. and boredom? Are smarter people more likely to not be bored because they've got greater intellectual resources, or am I just prejudiced in favor of smart people here? Well, I think it's a blessing and a curse because you can get bored for two reasons. One is you can get bored when something is too hard. And certainly having sort of more cognitive resources to bring to the table is going to reduce the times when something is too hard for you.
所以这是一个混杂的包，是的，可能有些情况下更聪明的人在寻找具有挑战性的、需要认知要求的任务方面有优势。
you simply sort of have a higher baseline chance of finding it interesting. But boredom is also caused by things that are too easy. And so there's actually research, I'm so sorry to tell you that there's actually research, some research that suggests that people with higher IQ or higher need for cognition may be sort of more susceptible to boredom, especially when it's caused by like repetitive monotonous tasks, precisely because they have so many resources,
有意思，而不是无聊。
that if you're like, you're sitting there and you have like, say, 10 resources and this monotonous, boring thing is only occupying two of them. There's this huge gap between what you are doing and what you could be doing. And when that happens, we find it hard to pay attention and that causes boredom. So it's sort of a mixed bag that like, yeah, there may be some instances where more intelligent people have a leg up on finding challenging sort of cognitively demanding tasks. interesting rather than boring. We know work from Paul Sylvia suggests that to feel interest in something, there has to be sort of a gap there where you don't understand it yet, but you feel like
我们知道保罗·西尔维亚（Paul Sylvia）的研究表明，要对某事产生兴趣，必须存在一定程度的差距，即你还不理解它，但你觉得你可以理解它。
you can understand it. And intelligence helps with that. But it also makes you more prone to this other source of boredom. And so I think it's, you win some, you lose some. In theory, you would think that people who sort of are smarter would be better at coming up with ways to fix boredom once it comes up. But what we don't see are strong ties between emotion regulation, as we call it, when it comes to boredom and intelligence. It doesn't seem like the case, for instance, necessarily from the very limited evidence that we have that once you are bored, that your sort of cognitive resources kind of
当你在研究无聊的问题时，你也在研究是什么让一个人变得无聊吗？
intelligence is going to influence whether you are not you're good at escaping that. As you look at the question of boredom, are you also looking at what makes an individual boring? Is that something that you have examined? Can we treat people who are boring? Yes, we have. This is very, none of this is published yet. It's still very exploratory. There's some work that Karen Gaspor and colleagues are doing on this question that suggest that when someone borrows us in conversation, we think badly of them. There's also work that I've been doing on what I call the only boring people or only boring people get bored, I thought.
是的。
Yeah. Which is, right, this idea that if you're bored, there must be something wrong with you. And the thing that's wrong with you is probably that you're a boring person. And so I've been looking at people's stereotypes about what is a boring person. and like. What do you think about boring people? Are people responsible for their own boredom? And all of that work is very preliminary. So we don't have good answers right now. But what I can tell you so far is that what you are sort of lay guesses or intuition look like are pretty consistent with what we're seeing in how people are rating boring people and who seems boring to them.
关于无聊的人以及谁对他们来说显得无聊，人们的直觉或猜测是什么样的。
There is work, and I love this work, so I'm just going to drop it in here, that if you're worried about being boring. The chances are that you're not as boring as you think you are. There's great work by Peggy Clark and colleagues that show that there's this sort of liking gap that we all kind of think that we're like less interesting and more boring and less likable than we actually are. But if you actually put us in conversations with each other and ask your partner how you were, they tend to sort of rate you more positively. So when it comes to worrying about you being boring, you're probably not as boring as you think you are. That's good to hear, especially for people who are kind of locked up with the same people day after day right now.
这真是个好消息，特别是对于现在日复一日和同样的人锁在一起的人来说。
You know, I was also looking at the work that you've been doing around categorization, which I found interesting because I'm a birder. So when I'm not stuck in the house, I mean, I like to go out and look at birds and some people think that that's crazy. But why are collecting and categorizing interesting to some of us and some of us, and some of the of us find it inherently meaningful. I love that you ask this. I have a question for you. Do you have a favorite bird? Oh, wow. That's hard. Where I live, one of the birds that I love to see, particularly this time of year, the male wood ducks, I think they're so beautiful. But I mean, there's so many, resplendent ketzal. I mean, how could, you know, but rosyate spoonbill, I could go on and on with birds. You see, now I'm going to get boring.
哦，哇。
I know. So the rosyate spoonbills just came to Florida. So I went out to see them right. before all the lockdown stuff happened. That was very exciting. And I ask you, because I think people who are in deport birds, you can hear it, right? It's exciting. And I have gotten into birding as a result of this research interest because I was looking at categorization. I was really struck by how many people, when I talk about this in lectures, I'm always, I always ask the audience, does anyone hear, is anyone here a bird watcher or a birder? And inevitably, one or two people kind of raise their hands, often kind of shyly.
我知道。
we get a bad rap and then I make it worse I'm like isn't it hilarious that grown adults go out and like count things like in the world but it is in the most wonderful of ways like I think it's absolutely wonderful and I think what's happening here
我们得到了一个坏名声，然后我让情况更糟糕了，我说：“成年人出去数世界上的一些东西，这难道不滑稽吗？”
is we've done a number of studies we're writing this up for publication right now that what categorization does for us and by categorization I mean any of these categorization hobbies so Shell Collect and bird watching. This work was actually inspired by a scuba diving trip to Honduras, where I brought a
这项工作实际上灵感来自于去洪都拉斯的深水潜水之旅，我在船上带了一张鱼类识别图，每个人都在取笑我，直到我们下水，然后他们都想要我的身份证。
fish identification chart with me on the boat and everyone was making fun of me until we got in the water and then they all wanted my identity card. And I didn't have it anymore. And I was like, well, it's on the boat. You know, you'd want to know this information. And we think what's happening is that when you see something, especially something that doesn't you don't have a good conception of or that doesn't make sense to you or you haven't made sense of.
你不会想要了解这些信息。
A categorization is a way of helping you literally create order and coherence in the world. That imagine, for instance, you're not a birder and you just heard our conversation about all these birds and you're just like, oh my God, there's just all these birds. What categorization lets you do is break that down into like, oh, no, there's this kind of bird and there's this kind of bird and there's this kind of bird. And we know that when we see patterns in the world, they feel meaningful to us. That patterns give us a sense of meaning, whether it's being able to sort of recognize and see patterns in the wildflowers or the birds or just even our own daily routines. Samantha Heinzelman has wonderful work that shows that people who have more
萨曼莎·海因泽尔曼（Samantha Heinzelman）有出色的研究表明，生活中更有规律的人在生活中体验到更多的意义。
routine in their lives experience more meaning in life. And they also feel like their lives are more meaningful while they're engaged in those routines. We really value this kind of predictability and coherence. And that's what categorization gives us is when we look at this big sort of mess out there in the world and then we can order it and put it into little boxes that lets us make sense of what's happening. And we experience that sense of making sense of what's happening as a sense of meaning. And that's a really powerful feeling for most of us. And it also, because meaning is related to boredom, reduces boredom and increases interest and enjoyment. I think that's great.
我认为这很棒。
I mean, it reminds me of taking walks in the woods with somebody who can identify plants, how that's a different experience from just walking and looking and not knowing what you're seeing. Just taking a tour of an art museum and having a docent or getting the headphones so that you understand what you're looking at. It certainly makes a lot of sense. No, it's a completely different experience. You know, in social psychology, we talk a lot about construals and that your emotions, and behavior and thoughts are shaped on your control or sort of understanding of what you're seeing. And categorization changes that when you see this painting as, when you understand its full historical
不，这完全是不同的体验。
significance or you understand that that weird little ugly plant there is actually a really rare and valuable native species that meets ants or something insane. It's a fundamentally different experience on every single level. You've also done research into procrastination, which I have to say it, kind of seems like you're trying to put a positive spin on a lot of stuff we do that gets a bad rap for being unimportant and not socially useful. But what are you learning about procrastination? And that grow out of your work on boredom? So procrastination, there's a saying in psychology, right, that research is knee search.
研究就是“膝跳搜索”。
I started working on procrastination as an undergraduate in a course that I took on motivation and self-regulation because I wanted to understand why I procrastinated all the time. And what I found out was really interesting is I went to a really small liberal arts college where there was this really strong sort of sense of academic identity and people really valued this idea of the intellectual life and academia for its own sake. And so it manifested in a lot of like academic bragging, but like not like I got a good grade, but like I stayed up until 6 a.m. working on my paper. And someone else was like, oh yeah, I haven't left the library in 48 hours.
实际上，我的大学甚至在凌晨2点关闭图书馆，以防止这种疯狂的行为。
In fact, my college actually started closing the library at 2 a.m. to prevent this kind of like insane behavior. And I became really interested in this question because what I noticed was that many of my peers that would brag about like having done nothing but work on this paper for the past week would be failing half their classes. And I was like, well, is it? it possible that you can procrastinate in ways that aren't what we typically conceptualize procrastination as? So we often think of procrastination, right? Is that instead of doing the thing you're supposed to be doing, you go off and watch Netflix or you go to a party or, you know, you do something that's sort of like fun and trivial. But that wasn't what I saw the students doing
我们经常认为拖延，对吧？
at this college. What I saw them doing was procrastinating on things that they really should have been doing, but they were procrastinating by doing other important things. They were doing other important schoolwork as a way of avoiding this, this task that they were putting off for some reason. And so I became interested in what I call productive procrastination. And by that, I mean procrastinating on something by doing something else that still has values. So like I said, studying for an exam instead of watching Netflix or it doesn't have to be in the same domain. You can procrastinate on one academic task by working on another academic task, and that could be productive. But you can also procrastinate on that academic task by doing the laundry or washing the dishes or baking bread or doing something that's productive but not necessarily academic.
你可以通过做另一项学术任务来拖延一项学术任务，这可能是富有成效的。
And so I'm not really interested in this question of like, one, is this a real thing or am I just sort of like making this up? like, do people actually engage in these different kinds of procrastination? And two, if they do, is, is it as bad as these classic ways of procrastinating, like blowing off your work to go party with friends or watch TV? And what we found was like twofold. So first of all, people absolutely report doing this. And this idea is out there everywhere in pop culture. Procrastabaking, right, is totally a phrase that people use. It was in the New York Times.
我知道。
and not too long ago is like a guide to procrastimaking. And we see people talk about it in everyday life, but we don't see it showing up in their research. So we just designed a study asking people, very descriptive, qualitative-ish study, basically looking at whether people first just do this and they do. It is as common, if not more common, than these sort of old-school traditional ideas of procrastination
不久前，‘拖延制造’就像是一本拖延症指南。我们在日常生活中经常听到人们谈论它，但它却没有体现在他们的研究中。所以我们专门设计了一项研究，通过非常具有描述性、偏质性的研究，基本上来看看人们是否首先会这样做，而他们确实这样做了。这种现象不仅常见，甚至比那些传统的、老派的拖延观念更为常见。
where you put off one important task by doing something, unimportant or a blow off thing instead. People were just as likely to say that they are putting off academic tasks by doing work for other classes or putting off a hard assignment by doing an easier assignment or putting off school work by cleaning the dishes. That was just as common as watching Netflix or doing something that had no point. And it's not just college students. Most of the work that we've done has been in academia and academics, both for convenience, and because that's where it's an obvious issue. But we've also done some work, for instance, with visitors to the North Carolina State Fair,
也就是通过做一些不重要的事情或者偷懒的事情来推迟一项重要的任务。人们同样倾向于说，他们会通过为其他课程写作业来推迟学术任务，或者通过做一件比较简单的作业来推迟困难的作业，或者通过洗碗来推迟学校的作业。这和看Netflix或者做一些毫无意义的事情一样普遍。而且这不仅仅发生在大学生身上。我们做过的大部分研究都是针对学术界和学者，这既是为了方便，也是因为在学术界这是一个显而易见的问题。但我们也做过一些其他研究，例如，针对北卡罗来纳州博览会的参观者，
which is a much broader group of people. It's just there are people that went to the fair and agreed to participate in a psych study. And we see similar rates when you ask about procrastinating on tasks at work or procrastinating on tasks around the home. So, for instance, I have still not filed my IRS returns. I'm absolutely procrastinating on that. But I feel justified because I've been working on great applications. Well, and they changed the deadline this year too.
这是一个范围更广的群体。他们只是去逛博览会并同意参与心理学研究的人。当你询问他们在工作中推迟任务或在家中推迟家务的情况时，我们发现其比例也是差不多的。所以，举个例子，我到现在还没有报税。我绝对是在拖延这件事。但我感到心安理得，因为我一直在忙着申请各种出色的项目。嗯，而且他们今年还更改了截止日期。
Oh, no, they changed the deadline. I will pretend like that's the reason why. But it also sounds like an issue of prioritization. I mean, I certainly work with people who, if you don't tell them, look, this is the most important thing you need to do today, that they don't understand that they'll do the thing that's maybe fifth or sixth down the list in my mind. I mean, is that different? Or is that the same kind of procrastination? I think it's subjective.
哦，不，他们更改了截止日期。我会假装这就是原因。但这听起来也像是一个优先级的问题。我的意思是，我确实和这样的人共事过：如果你不告诉他们，听着，这是你今天必须做的最重要的事情，他们就不会明白，他们会去做我脑海中排在第五或第六位的事情。我的意思是，这有什么不同吗？还是说这和那种拖延是一回事？我认为这因人而异。
I think it counts as procrastination when you know you should be doing it but choose not to. So if you legitimately don't think you should be doing it. So I think that's actually why this is a great example. I think the tax return is procrastination in my case because I know I should be doing it and I'm deliberately putting it off by doing other things and make me feel better about it not doing it. But someone else, like my father also hasn't filed his tax. return isn't planning to do so until the end of April. But in his case, he rationally looked at the extended deadline and said, you know what, like, it makes sense for me to wait and do this later
我认为，当你明知自己应该去做却选择不做时，这就属于拖延。所以，如果你理直气壮地认为自己不该做这件事。所以我认为这实际上就是为什么这是一个很好的例子。我认为在我的案例中，报税就是拖延，因为我知道我应该去做，而我却通过做其他事情来故意推迟它，这让我觉得不做这件事也没那么内疚。但其他人，比如我父亲也没有报税，而且他不打算在4月底之前做这件事。但在他的情况中，他理性地查看了延后的截止日期，然后说，你知道吗，对我来说，等待一段时间再做是合理的，
because this is other really important stuff I have to do. And in that case, I would say that is not procrastinating. He does, he's not putting it off. He doesn't think he should do it now. He very legitimately has simply reordered his priorities to reflect. It's a conscious decision. Yes. And so I think procrastination is in some ways a subjective state. that it depends on the psychology of why people are doing it and how they feel about it. The good news, this is very preliminary, but we do have data that for academic procrastination, at least, that I'm not going to go so far as to say you should do productive procrastination. That's definitely too far.
因为我还有其他非常重要的事要做。在这种情况下，我会说这不是拖延。他没有在推迟。他并不认为自己现在就该做。他非常合情合理地重新安排了优先级以作反应。这是一个有意识的决定。是的。所以我觉得拖延在某种程度上是一种主观状态，它取决于人们这样做的心理以及他们的感受。好消息是，这还非常初步，但我们确实有数据表明，至少对于学术拖延而言——我不会走得太远去说你应该进行有成效的拖延。那绝对有点过头了。
But when we compare people that don't procrastinate at all, which is an embarrassingly large percentage of humanity I've discovered. Who do a lot? I know. Depending on the study, it's, you know, I'm like 25 to 30, 40% of people that, like, you know, everyone's human, but by and large, they tend not to procrastinate. When you look at people that engage in a lot of productive procrastination, so putting off their taxes to apply for grants or putting off studying for an exam to work on a paper assignment, they don't look any different in terms of their college GPAs.
但当我们把那些完全不拖延的人进行对比时，我发现这部分人群占了人类中令人尴尬的巨大比例。有很多这样的人吗？我知道。根据研究的不同，大概有25%到30%、40%的人，你知道的，每个人都是人，但大体上，他们倾向于不拖延。当你观察那些进行大量有成效的拖延的人时，比如推迟报税去申请补助金，或者推迟复习考试去写论文，他们在大学GPA方面并没有什么不同。
Their GPAs look about the same. It doesn't look like their grades are suffering. because of this decision overall. The other thing that we find is that when you engage in productive procrastination in this way, it doesn't seem like it puts you at risk for alcohol use and risky alcohol drinking in the same way that we often see with other forms of procrastination. So that classic procrastination where you blow off your schoolwork to go party or go watch Netflix, that's associated with a lot of problems just with self-regulation in general and self-control
他们的GPA看起来差不多。从总体决策来看，他们的成绩似乎并没有因此受到影响。我们发现的另一件事是，当你以这种方式进行有成效的拖延时，它似乎不会像我们经常在其他形式的拖延中看到的那样，让你面临酗酒和危险饮酒的风险。因此，那种经典的拖延——你把学业抛在一边去开派对或看Netflix，这通常与整体自我调节和自我控制方面的很多问题息息相关。
in general. And we see a lot of correlations there between people that procrastinate in those ways and increased risk of alcohol use disorder, increased risk of hazards, just drinking in college, you know, binge drinking, all that sort of stuff tends to go along as a package with that behavioral profile. And that's really not what we see for the productive procrastinators. I'm writing up a paper right now, But our current thinking is that productive procrastination may be an unorthodox but acceptable variant that people use to emotionally cope with tasks that are difficult and hard for them to do in some way that at least you're not totally disengaging. You know, if I'm having a really hard time on this school assignment and I decided to work on this other assignment for school, I'm still engaged academically. I'm not losing my overall academic motivation. and I may be better prepared to circle back and work on that original task that I put off at a later date.
总的来说。我们看到那些以这种方式拖延的人与酒精使用障碍风险增加、饮酒危害风险增加之间存在很多相关性，在大学里就是酗酒，所有这些往往都与这种行为模式打包出现。这确实不是我们在高效拖延者身上看到的。我现在正在写一篇论文，但我们目前的想法是，高效拖延可能是一种非正统但可以接受的变通方法，人们用它来在情感上应付那些对他们来说很困难、很难完成的任务，至少你没有完全脱离状态。你知道，如果我在完成这个学校作业时遇到了很大的困难，而我决定做学校的另一个作业，我仍然在学术上保持参与。我没有失去整体的学术动力，而且我可能做好了更好的准备，以便在稍后的日期回过头来处理我推迟的那个最初的任务。
So productive procrastination, I don't go so far as to say that a positive or a good thing, but I don't think it's a bad thing and I don't think people need to feel as guilty about that kind of procrastination as they do for just blowing it all off and going and doing something fun instead. Yeah. That makes sense. Any final words of advice for our listeners who might be feeling bored or maybe putting off doing things that they could be doing right now? Yeah, so I'm going to tackle those separately because I have two sets of tips. One for procrastination, Alexandra Forrand and Zurich has fabulous data showing that there's a really nifty trick that you can do with procrastination to help. And I read about this in the research literature. I cite it in my papers all the time and I use it in my own life.
所以对于高效拖延，我不会走得太远去说它是一件积极的或好的事情，但我不认为这是一件坏事，而且我认为人们不需要对这种拖延感到那么内疚，就像他们因为把事情全抛在一边转而去玩乐而感到内疚那样。是的，这说得通。对于我们的听众，如果他们感到无聊，或者可能在推迟他们现在本可以去做的事情，你有什么最后的建议吗？好的，我将把这两点分开来谈，因为我有两套建议。一条是关于拖延的，亚历山大·福兰（Alexandra Forrand）在苏黎世有着极好的数据，表明有一个非常巧妙的诀窍可以用来应对拖延并发挥作用。我在研究文献中读到过这个，我在论文中经常引用它，而且我在自己的生活中也在使用它，
and I've personally replicated it with a sample of one many times, and I find it helpful. And the idea is that a lot of times when you're dreading doing a task, there's two different reasons you might dread doing it. You might dread actually doing it. Like, oh, I don't want to sit down and do this super monotonous complicated thing. Or you might dread doing it because the stakes are so high. Like, oh, I know it's just this one little email to send to someone, but I'm really worried about how they're going to respond.
我曾多次用个人的单一样本进行复制，我发现它很有用。这个想法是，很多时候当你畏惧做一项任务时，你可能会畏惧做它的两个不同原因。你可能会畏惧实际去做它。比如，哦，我不想坐下来做这个超级单调、复杂的事情。或者你可能会因为风险太高而畏惧去做它。比如，哦，我知道这只是发给某人的一个小邮件，但我真的很担心他们会如何回应，
and if they respond badly, it's going to ruin everything. And so what Alexander Ford finds is that if you can figure out why you're putting it off, you can focus on the other thing instead. So if you don't want to do your taxes because I don't want to go and find all the little forms and do all the little numbers and like, where is my W2? Oh, I moved institutions. I need to find my lat, you know, all these little, like the nitty-gritty details. By shifting my focus to why I'm doing it, the bigger overarching abstract.
如果他们反应不好，一切都会被毁掉。所以亚历山大·福兰发现，如果你能弄清楚你为什么要推迟它，你就可以转而专注于另一件事。因此，如果你不想报税，因为我不想去找所有的小表单，填写所有的数字，比如，我的W2表格在哪里？哦，我换了单位。我需要找到我过去的，你知道，所有这些琐碎的细节。通过将我的焦点转移到我为什么要这样做上，也就是更大、更宏观、更抽象的，
goal, like, oh, you know, I'm going to get a tax refund. I'm going to not get in trouble with the IRS. That can increase motivation and make it easier to actually just get started and do the task. So if you're put off by the detail, the nitty-gritty details, focusing on the bigger reason for why you're doing it helps. And conversely, if you're putting it off because the big reason that you're doing it is so, you know, stressful or overwhelming, it helps to instead shift to the nitty-gritty details and be like, okay, like, you know, instead of focusing about like how this email is going to make or break my career, I'm just going to focus on writing it one word at a time. And that that kind of shift in level helps people fix the problem. And I think that's actually a valuable lesson for
目标上，比如，哦，你知道，我要拿到退税了。我不会惹上税务麻烦。这可以增加动力，并使实际开始并完成任务变得更容易。因此，如果你被细节、琐碎的细节所阻碍，专注于你为什么要这样做的更大原因会有所帮助。相反，如果你因为这样做的重大原因让人感到压力山大或不堪重负而推迟它，那么转向琐碎的细节并告诉自己“好吧，你知道的，与其纠结这封邮件会成就还是毁掉我的职业生涯，我不如专注于把它一个字一个字地写好”，这会有所帮助。这种层面的转变有助于人们解决问题。我认为这实际上是一个宝贵的教训，
boredom in general, because often, not always, but procrastination is about anticipating that something's going to make you feel anxious or anticipating that something's going to make you feel bored. And we know that we can reduce boredom by fixing the problems that caused it. You know, so we open today where it's talking about how boredom signals that you're not able to pay attention or that what you're doing doesn't feel meaning. But that also gives you the information you need to stop feeling bored. If you feel bored because what you're doing doesn't have meaning, maybe you should either go do something else or find a way to see the meaning in what you're doing.
对于一般的无聊感也是如此，因为通常情况下，虽不总是如此，但拖延往往源于预见到某事会让你感到焦虑，或者预见到某事会让你觉得无聊。我们知道，我们可以通过解决导致无聊的问题来减少无聊。你知道的，我们在今天开篇时谈到了无聊如何表明你无法集中注意力，或者你正在做的事情感觉没有意义。但这同时也为你提供了停止感到无聊所需的信息。如果你感到无聊是因为你做的事情没有意义，也许你应该要么去做别的事情，要么找一种方法去发现你正在做的事情的意义。
So for right now, for instance, we're all under these stay-at-home orders. And that doesn't feel like we're doing much. It doesn't feel super meaningful. I know it is objectively, but it doesn't feel that way. So anything we can do to remind ourselves and keep that frame in mind that what I'm doing right now, literally by sitting at my desk is saving lives. Right, right. You know, any way that you can increase the meaning of what you're doing,
所以就目前而言，例如，我们都处于居家令之下。这感觉不像我们在做很多事情。这感觉不是很有意义。我知道从客观上讲是的，但感觉并非如此。所以我们可以做任何事情来提醒自己并保持那种框架，即我现在正在做的事情，仅仅是通过坐在我的办公桌前就是在拯救生命。对，对。你知道，任何能增加你所做事情意义的方法，
whether it's a reminder on the fridge or talking about it with others, it literally makes us feel less bored because it infuses everything you're doing with a sense of meaning. And that sort of quietes down all those sort of. of like parts of your mind that are alerting you that what you're doing isn't meaningful because you're saying yes, yes, it is. And the same thing goes for attention, that if you're having trouble concentrating because things are too hard right now, it's okay to listen to that signal and back off and step it down to a level that you can handle or conversely if you don't have enough to occupy your days, sort of use it as license. If that's where you're at, not everyone is,
无论是冰箱上的提醒便签，还是与他人谈论它，这确实让我们感到没那么无聊，因为它为你在做的每件事注入了一种意义感。这在某种程度上平息了你脑海中所有那些向你发出警报、提醒你所做的事情没有意义的部分，因为你在说：是的，是的，它是有意义的。同样的道理也适用于注意力，如果你因为现在事情太难而难以集中注意力，倾听这个信号并退一步，将其降低到你能应付的水平是没问题的；相反，如果你的日子里没有足够的事情来填补，就把这当成一种许可。如果你的处境确实如此，虽然不是每个人都这样，
but if you're at that point where you want to engage in some new hobbies or download that book you've always been meeting during, that can be a great fit for people, too. I think fixing boredom and fixing procrastination are really about listening to your emotions and listening to the information that those emotions are trying to tell you. We have this idea that emotions are irrational and they're not. They're so rational. They're like our internal messaging service to tell us what's going on with our minds. And by listening to them, we can get that information and use that information to fix them and feel better.
但如果你正处于那种想要培养一些新爱好或下载你一直想读的那本书的阶段，这对于人们来说也是一个很好的契合点。我认为克服无聊和克服拖延实际上都是关于倾听你的情绪，并倾听这些情绪试图告诉你信息的。我们有一种观念认为情绪是不理性的，其实它们并非如此。它们非常理性。它们就像我们的内部消息服务，告诉我们大脑中发生了什么。通过倾听它们，我们可以获得这些信息，并利用这些信息来解决问题，让自己感觉更好。
Well, that's all great advice. So Dr. Westgate, thank you so much for joining Speaking of Psychology. I have to say I found our conversation to be anything but boring. So thank you. Thank you so much. That's always my fear. And for our listeners, if you have any comments or ideas that you want to share with our podcast, you can send an email to Speaking of Psychology at APA.org.
好吧，这些都是很棒的建议。韦斯特盖特博士，非常感谢您做客《心理学对话》。我必须说，我们的对话可以说是妙趣横生，绝不枯燥。非常感谢。非常感谢。这一直是我最害怕的。对于我们的听众，如果您有任何评论或想法想要与我们的播客分享，您可以发送电子邮件至 Speaking of Psychology at APA.org。
That's Speaking of Psychology, all one word, at APA.org. You can find previous episodes of Speaking of Psychology. on Apple, Stitcher, Spotify, or wherever you get your podcasts. You can also go to our website and download all the episodes at www. www.spicingsingsology.org. Thanks again for listening for the American Psychological Association. I'm Kim Mills. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
那是 Speaking of Psychology，所有单词连在一起，at APA.org。您可以在 Apple、Stitcher、Spotify 或您获取播客的任何地方找到往期的《心理学对话》。您也可以访问我们的网站并下载所有节目，网址是 www.spicingsingsology.org。再次感谢收听美国心理学协会节目。我是金·米尔斯。本期节目暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。